also salmon
my name is we have expected who's gonna
be holding a photograph Dutch Mahanama
gloomy decoder honk let me feel a
problem may happen and there's the good
reason that I should speak in English
could you switch the clip or ah okay now
it works it was just a few a very short
list of the names I see on the post that
is coming to my home on my cards from
different organizations and companies
but this is how it should be written
okay and sometimes I even then I see
this text my name is never /i Devine
this is the first line over there there
is how you pronounce it with the IPA and
the second line is how you can type it
correctly using the compose key I've
worked at the solute egg in Baja in
Karlsruhe in southern Germany which is
the Silver Sponsor here at pykon de we
are standing behind the large one of the
largest price comparing websites in
Germany billy goat a a and if you would
like to come to a city where both
bicycle and car were born and where we
drink both beer and wine from half liter
glass is speak to me or to my colleagues
afterwards so what are we going to talk
about we are going to talk about the
peyten
so how to work with names or general
strings in Python so comparing strings
bytes encoding normalizing case folding
so upper case lower case sorting
alphabetical sorting and regular
expressions and on the other hand how to
work with names on the websites or in
the databases the concept of first last
names middle names and how you should
proceed with allowed characters in the
names hello titan-3
also the finally the greater distinction
between strings and bytes
what is a string string is a series of
characters each character is one of the
over 1 million code points of Unicode
and this is what work would you have in
the working memory
you don't really mind how one can
looks like if it is one bite or several
bites long because it is in the memory
you access it you'll see the length of
this character as one and it offers you
over 1 million code points so most
alphabets and a lot of symbols that are
used all around the world on the other
hand we have bytes which is something
that you write into a file on your fee
disk or you send over Network and this
is something that has only 256 possible
combinations so we have to find a way
how to encode our strings from the
characters into these bytes if your name
is Chuck Nori's you need no encoding but
anyway in Python if you take the string
which is string in quotes without
anything before and you encode it you
convert it from string into bytes there
is a small B before these modes and on
the other hand if you read some bytes
you just decode them and you get the
string in this case this is only a pure
ASCII so the length of both the string
and off the bytes is 12 the language 12
so there is no problem and this is how
it would work actually also in Python 2
but where there comes the difference for
example
milah determine name the contents a you
with two dots which converts into bytes
using two bytes you need to bite so this
is the number two and the number three
on the right hand Python uses as a
default utf-8 so you don't really have
to take care of that as long as you are
the master of all your of your whole
code and your whole data this works also
for some other characters for example
Chinese this is not a last name this is
me how so hello in Chinese and so using
utf-8 we take our two characters as a
string and we converts them to six
characters as a as a bytes and you can
write it on the disk or sense to them I
sent over the network okay
default in Python is utf-8 but we can
use also other Aquatics because there
are plenty plenty plenty of encodings
out there as
is the basic one in this case his name
contains only ASCII characters so there
is not a problem
if you have some German name with the
you with the RSS you can use for example
at in one and then encoding this you
with two dots convert it to one byte and
visa-versa you take the bytes and then
decode them there is no information
about the encoding in the bytes so you
have to know what you are doing with it
my in my case my last name shaggy
becomes from czechoslovakia it means
grey haired don't believe that the last
name mean anything in this case the
capital S with Karen and the Y with
acute they can convert into a single
byte in Latin - but I cannot used it in
Latin one and vice versa latin one is
for languages like German French Italian
Spanish West European Latin 2 is for
Latin based is your central european
languages polish Hungarian Czech Slovak
and Slovenian and a few other languages
this is what I see sometimes when I get
mail actually they upgrade it since 2
years know when this appeared I tweeted
them that you have all my contact data
you can contact me I know how to solve
this today they didn't contact me but
nowadays all the packages I get from
them they remove - the question mark and
the why at the end so I am just Miroslav
space space Eddie you have seen that at
the beginning so the question is how is
this possible because on their website I
entered JAV correctly and it is printed
correctly on the website but on the
packages there is a question mark where
does this question mark come from if I
take my last name as a string and I
encoded into Latin - I will get
something that is represented correctly
this is a six characters if I account it
into Latin one because this is a company
based in Germany probably this is what
they are doing if they use peyten and
they encode it to let in one they will
get an exception because the let the
character the first character is s with
curandera cannot be encoded in latin one
but they still
nh-2 send me packages there is a switch
that you can with encode inlet in one
and then you say okay if there is a
error
don't raise an exception but replace it
and the default it will be replaced with
a question mark so actually you can this
you can there is work I think you can
raise an exception you can replace it
question mark is the only possibility
and you can other possibilities just to
skip the character so this is how it is
possible so please if you can use utf-8
something different is this is some
random I like company in Germany I
wanted to buy a ticket and I wrote my
last name and they told me you can only
enter letters in the adults last name
field sorry my last name consists of
letters look what is a letter you can do
this in Python 3 you can write a word
with some beyond ASCII characters equals
and in the string but you cannot give
you name your variable a smiley or dot
or a question mark how the spite know
about it despite know all these
characters with all the currents and
Chinese characters you can use train
these characters for that there is a
category so if you category of character
if you import unit unicode data which is
in standard Python library then you can
ask for the category and the name of a
character so for example I have here a
list of some ace umlaut surfaces there
is even capital surfaces which exist in
German you see it is a little bit wider
there is dot and smiley and then with
this short program I can just get the
character its category and its name so
what you see in the first column it is
the name how it looks like and then the
second column with this else that these
two characters it is the category of the
character and if it is an L at the
beginning capital L it means that is a
letter and you or L afterwards it may be
uppercase or lowercase and this is how
peyten knows that okay everything but
that contains characters that are
categorized as letters you can use them
as variable names the attention if
you'll compete Wrentham code from
stackoverflow and it doesn't work really
exactly as you would expect check
whether some variable names are maybe
serially glitters that are very similar
or identical looking to the Latin
alphabet so you can have an A or a they
look the same in both Cyrillic and Latin
but they are two different characters so
the variable name is different so this
is how you can actually security through
obscurity if you want to make your code
obscure you just rendered randomly and
consistently switch the character is
some variable characters for a Cyrillic
okay and then like the n small letter a
it is the name of the character like
it's sorta officially at Unicode this is
the list of all categories so you see
all the ELLs it is those letters then
ends are some numbers punctuation and so
on there is operating system there is
usual it is this is usually the
character map ipler app that allows you
to find a character and down you see
this 161 not three Unicode zero one six
zero this is a hexadecimal letting
capital letter as with current and this
is what allows you to use other
characters in your code if you are not
able to type them directly or if you
want to keep your code ASCII so for
example what I could do with my last
name I just like slash you and execute a
single code zero one six zero and for
the Y it is XY 0 0 0 FD and this is pure
asking but it translates into my last
name other possibility is to use the
name this is even better to read
probably like you can better remember if
you see Latin capital letter S with
Karen then to remember what 0-1-6-0 code
means and this way you can really enter
some fancy stuff from the charm app that
you like and in your code you can still
see what it should contain when it is
printed he's holding this is upper case
lower case it's simple you have the
upper
get it one way and not slower to get it
our other way but there are a few bugs
that spawned not really bugs but
something that doesn't work correctly
with what is in the reality of our human
languages for example the surfaces if
you do chef is a pretty little over K is
any converted to uppercase you will get
an S capital if you then convert it to
lowercase again then you get an SSL over
K so you don't get the surfaces again on
the other hand this works if you take
the traffic this upper case you can
lower case it's 2 into the lower case of
surfaces and there is one more back but
this is a back in our in our Latin
alphabet and there is one of the 26
letters that is actually wrong and
Python does it wrong which one is it
hi see this there is a lowercase I with
a dot that converts into an uppercase I
without that does anyone understand
Turkish here they have I with the doc
lowercase uppercase is e and I lowercase
and uppercase without that is how should
Turkish people convert their texts
between upper case and lower case if we
have broken their alphabet there is a
way I will have a look at this ICU
library little bit later you can do that
correctly but not with a standard upper
and lower normalising we have two
character a little strings the one is
used like sweet it can be also last name
in in German and the vert tool looks the
same but it is normalized what is the
difference between these two words the
first one I just printed all the
characters the first views has three
characters s and prophesize the word 2
contains of four characters so if you
compare these two verses are no equal
the length is not equal and if you
access different characters they are not
equal as well but when you print it it
looks the same but you see in the vert
tool the character number two these
theorises
it is not my mistake
if you
actually really offset by one because
this combining diuresis doesn't have a
wit if you want to combine to put some
bit keys or some extra extra marks on
your letter you put it afterwards and
then it doesn't have a width so it means
that you enter the errors is it combines
together to the you with two dots Titan
is in this case is very smart that you
cannot normalize and de normalize
anything so for example what I can do I
can take a chef as s and then put
combining the or resist after it but
when I de normalize it so I want to get
the shorter version of the words I don't
get a character there is no character
which offices video raises on it
so the it knows that okay you can
combine only characters that are
possible to combine because otherwise
you would get something like this which
is a stick or flow answer for a question
how can I use reg X to parse HTML and
you see here at the end this is actually
some random character with a lot a lot a
lot of combining characters afterwards
so then another topic is alphabetic
sorting these are some letters imagine
these are the first letters of some
names when you sort them using Python
just like this first you get all the SQL
capital at low upper case then ask a
lower case like aou then you get the
umlauts upper case then the surface is
then the umlauts lower case then some
letters characters from Central Europe
like the edge and the capital chávez's
comes at the end because it was added to
Unicode a little bit later so this is
not how you want to sort alphabetically
and I don't really my last name is
Reggie V I don't really enjoy it
conference is to be always at the end of
the alphabetic list of the speakers
because in Czech and Slovak edge is
between SMT I don't know in German is
probably different in English is again
different in Hungarian is probably
different we are going to have a look at
it but if you use this this is probably
not what you want
if you want to sort alphabetically in
the German logic logic you import locale
then change the locale to de de utf-8
and then we started and you see that the
A's they land just between a and B and
the uppercase lowercase letter cells are
also together on the other hand when you
do something with Swedish the umlauts
aloud and the O with the circle there at
the end of alphabet after that so if
you'll sort the Swedish way it will look
a little bit different in Hungarian
there is C as this lateral this just
sound but it is CS and also particularly
it comes after C so CV likes weekly and
cheaper they are in that order because
CS is not between C R and C T it is
after season in Czech and Slovak as I
told you sure is between s and T choice
between C and D and we have this letter
huh CH that is between H and I and this
is also sometimes problematic because
usually in Czech and Slovak if you see
CH its but sometimes they are composed
vert that one word ends with the C the
other one begins with an H and then it
is not a her these are two C and H
letters so next to each other so even
they this doesn't always work correctly
French there are some rules some French
official dictionaries that use this rule
that they sort everything alphabetically
but when it comes to accents they saw
them starting from the end of the world
so we first sort all the last two
syllables than the before last and then
the other way around the problem with
locale is that it is connected to the
process so if you change the locale the
whole process has been changed so it
means if you have some process on web
server and there is there is some user
that wants to see a list of the names
sorted the German way is with your basic
way any then if you set lock held and
the whole process will be changed this
is not what you want that's why it's
better to use this e ICU international
components for Unicode and then you
create an instance in that language and
then you can sort in the language
without
changing the appeal of the process and
this is also what can be used to
uppercase lowercase the Turkish
characters now regular expressions let's
say we want to extract from this text
the word mutant you can how can we do it
if we extract every all letters A to Z
then we could only the M and then hen we
ignore the when we use the backslash V
all sorry based RW like flesh W then we
will get even the numbers but we don't
want the numbers so we want to find a
way how to extract everything that is a
character for that we have we will have
to use the third-party library reg X
that works the same like the standard re
but it allows you with the backslash key
in the curly braces to include the
category of the letter that you want so
for example the capital L is everything
that is letter with Lu you have
uppercase letters with LL you have
lowercase letters and this is how you
can do it okay I came here for patent
but I said for the names how many of you
have any problems with like encoding or
ordering or first name last name I think
that I have here all the pykon
participants that are not have no ASCII
names happy to see that who have you
have simply first name last name okay
first name middle name last name first
name patronymic surname patronymic last
name as only metonymic patronymic a
surname okay this is modern spanish and
portuguese way of doing the things there
are also for example in the northern
countries for example iceland as this
the concept of the first name of the
father for all first name and the first
name of the father with the sun so for
example if someone is called Seager and
his father is Johann then his see were
your hands on but they never call him
mr. Johansson his name starts with an S
so alphabetically sorted after Seager
and he is mr. Ziegler Johansson
last name first name any Hungarians or
is your Asians here so again this is not
last name if it comes first any kings or
Pope's here Vienna - now just simple
name yeah and then imagine all this
phone on - and all these aristocratic
titles sometimes they are part of the
name sometimes there are certain
sometimes not and even worse are all the
doctors because if you doctor in Germany
your doctor you get it as a part of your
last name but it's when there is a first
name that he turns in between so now
imagine that in all the languages it's
different very different but maybe if
you are here at the conference you have
seen we have sorted you according to the
first name actually we took the whole
string of your name and then just okay
this is your full name no matter whether
you are doctor or first name last name
and anyway you you order your name it
will be just one string or one field in
the database and there is something like
how should we call you this is probably
I think the best way to to store names
because with all the first name last
name it simply doesn't work ok there
isn't
except instantly said ok what is your
first name is a first name is mr. my
middle name is period and my last name
is T so don't when you do something with
the names don't assume anything don't
want random limit on their length so if
there is something like what type the
fourth letter of your last name and I
know there is someone here with three
letters last name there is someone with
two letters on me yeah
okay so there are even longer names on
the other way or this way I mean I think
in this case they didn't mistake in his
name in Wikipedia and nobody noticed it
even in summer don't you stop words if
it is an offensive word in your language
is probably a normal name in other
language family members don't have
necessarily the same family name yes all
the male members of my family are
all three Kiwi the females are Shakira
because it is an adjective
in Czech and in Slovak as I said
gray-haired and also in Czech and Slovak
we put over at the end of female names
if the last name of the man is is the
substantive difference transcriptions
from non-latin alphabets so for example
you know Anton Pavlovich Trejo
there are plenty plenty of in every
language they transcribe the Russian
name differently the other way around as
well on in my passport I was in Russia
in the past few years twice and I have
two visa for Russia and my CV my last
name is written in Cyrillic alphabet
differently in both ways so if there is
some Soviet or some Russian organization
that that takes care of me they see me
as two different people persons probably
Chinese the same and other languages as
well men they can change their family
names too so if you ask for the maiden
name or nay it's probably not what is
applicable to men as well and one lesser
name is probably not an initial so Ben
what the Mandel brought this day is
actually only a letter P and not not a
whole lot an abbreviation of a funny so
probably you should expect that
everything that is printable is fine and
it's a part of lighter because you
cannot say that only letters are allowed
because there are some dishes or some
apostrophe so there are people who think
that they have problems with their names
even if they are for completely asking
if your computer with your program your
application has problem with mister now
please see me after the talk there are
ways to get null into the database
without problems I have seen somewhere
as how someone told me yesterday that
someone in the USA wanted to have a car
plate with now so that they do
he cannot be entered into the database
if he should get a split ticket
the problem was that he got all the
speed tickets of everyone that couldn't
be where the classes played was not
readable now if your database is problem
with now you will probably have problems
with these names as well okay how about
names of trees and cities because cities
are threes are sometimes called after
people as well who knows what is the
most common street name in Germany hmm
house gang no you can find it quite
often on the streets if you park your
car somewhere and remember I part here
no you are not going to find it again on
the other hand but there are few names
of streets in Germany that I do not find
them in Germany but you find them for
example on American lists of companies
directories of companies for example how
much trauma Bay now if you will find it
quite often there are places so you
don't have to limit the length of the
city at least three characters no don't
do that because all this is somewhere in
Scandinavia like somewhere in France the
habitants are called epsilon yeah and
there are also other extremes oh no ok
of course this so if you have a question
what is our mother's might name or where
were you born at least six characters
should contain uppercase lowercase and
digits and so on now okay and there are
places like one part book wing gecko
graph in durable quantity Leo go go go
that is even longer or okay this is
fiction
very famous of a Polish movie where the
men person ultra confidentially kovitch
and the place he pretends to live in is
transition where she separated when
comedy the face of the German soldier
looks like that for the whole two
minutes after that and even sometimes
you even don't have addresses so in
Iceland you just shall die draw a map
and the letter will rise
I'm almost in the half of my talk now
but now I'm going to go really fast
because this is just a list of
falsehoods programmers belief about
names so I'm going to let you read it
all of that because every time you try
to write a program that has assumes that
are okay of course this has to be like
that no it can be everything okay at
last assume no people don't always have
names so what to do please respect your
users names and don't break the locale
when you program so import this I see
you third-party library when you work
with bytes from the network or file read
this vise as soon as possible convert
them to a string using the right
encoding and on the other hand when
exporting Kangol them as fast as
possible as late as possible UTF school
is school for utf-8 is cool pythons free
school and be cool to please and please
telling the user your name is invalid
only because of laziness ignorance and
spitefulness prevents you from handling
their input is not cool be nice thank
you very much
[Applause]
Thank You Mira
do we have questions microphone please I
just want to add that in Portuguese we
have the mother name and the father name
but in a different order than in Spanish
but there is no difference between how a
mother female name and father's are
males names the sounds so it's not like
in Slovakia anyone else has their
current mother's surname anyone has no
name I have not seen such name which
with without names anybody has questions
about their own names excellent talk
have you ever got a chance to work with
Indian languages because there are some
characters in the language letters the
character so there's this applicable
like I see you and Unicode libraries
does this applicable even for Indian
languages in which language is Indian
Indian yes like we have multiple
languages like you may have some 2,000
languages in the country if you have if
you have if you are if the characters of
these languages are in Unicode then they
are defined category as letters so you
can use them you can parse them actually
as letters okay even if you someone use
these Japanese letters as Smiley's it
was the shi shi i think then these are
letters
any more questions anyone everyone wants
to go to the lunch
I guess one question for me any advice
about how to approach sort inquiry when
we don't know the local you probably you
can use this you do us the English
sorting or any sorting because then it
will be always better than the primitive
Titan like the simple part Titan sorting
that sources according to Unicode
because at least English knows that
uppercase lowercase should go together
and very probably offices will be
somewhere at the end of the alphabet but
at least sure will be hopefully
somewhere before surfaces so you said
that we should know what the what the
encoding of the bytes is that we're
loading yeah what do we do when we don't
you try there are there are some
encoding that can be load that can be
detected utf-8 for example has some
security mechanism but for the others if
you know which language it should be in
then you can actually sell okay in
German I allow only these diseases these
characters so there should be no other
but nowadays if I write something in
German I sign it automatically there is
a character that is now in not in German
so I will probably break your program
but we'd finish you can do probably you
have probably no problems okay I think
that's all the questions we have
thank you Mira again thank you
[Applause]